STREAK
THEY DROPPED 4 OF THE LAST 5
AND THEY HAVS YEARS CAUGUG
HE HAD TWOE LAST TWO
SEASON THEM.
I WILL BE WATCHING THE SHARKS
AND HOW THEY MATCH U
BALCERD
CONTACT LIKE
THAT AND TERRARO
>> NO BLOCK K ND IT.
AND THE PUCK LOOSE AND IT WORKS
UP THE LEFT SIDE, HEE GETS IT BP
SIGNING WITH THE SHARKS AS A
FREE AGENT
D HE THE DEFENSEMAM C.
>> YEAH, NO CALL
IT'S A PENALTYE HOCKEY>> ANOTHEM
PESCE, N CHANCES
PUT HERTL AND MEIER AND CO AT HE
BY WASHINGTON ON SATURDAY  SHOTR
BREN YEAH, OFF OF MIDDLETON'S NT
FORECHECK, GOOD BODY CHECK
AND THEN, RIGHT THIS, HE GIVES,
5 ON 5
SHARKS
CHIPS IN BEYOND  SEE HIM OUT
HERE CREATING ACTION TO THE NET.
SCOTT REEDY.
RUBBED TO TAKE
IT TO THE FRONT OF THE NET
HE DOES HERE
JUST GETTING IN ON
CAN'T GET PAST SKJEI, GETS BACK
ON SIDE.
RECE
SHOT, UP AND OUT OF PLAY WITH
1:46 TO GO
>> GOOD D SKJEI, AND IT'S INTER
BY 21.2 TO GO.
>> WE HAD TO WAIT FOR A POWER
PLAY, BUT TH AND HERTL
WITH A SWING AND PAD SAVE BY TO
AHO THE FACE-OFF THERE ANDO HER.
SHOT